latest on where we are right now we're
joined by CBS News medical contributor
dr. David agus dr. good morning morning
Jeff we we saw you last week well first
of all there are a lot of disagreements
over how country should handle this and
all countries are taking different
approaches to what's happening right now
many disagreements in your estimation
doctor where are we right now and what
else should we be doing you know I'm
proud I mean I'm honestly proud how the
country stepped up these fast few days
and we've seen it we've seen schools
closing businesses working from home
we've seen all of us as a country gather
together to really make an impact on the
spread of this virus and it's going to
work we are going to slow the spread of
this virus we're not there yet and it
may go up before it goes down but
there's it there's a change happening in
our country I think we all can feel it
we also at the same time have the drugs
that that look optimistic and they're
coming down the pipeline so you couple
that together with the medical
infrastructure that's also expanding and
it really is for the first time I'm
seeing a light at the end of the tunnel
doctor there are still a lot of people
that there's a disconnect here they
don't understand the extremes we're
taking because this is not necessarily a
death sentence so is it the spike in the
infection rate over a period of time a
short period of time that is the chief
concern no question about is that when
we're gonna see over the next several
weeks is there's going to be a lot more
infection first of all we're gonna test
for it we never know you know the true
denominator the true number of people
with it until we actually do the testing
we're going to start doing mass testing
over the next couple of weeks and we're
gonna see that this virus is in many of
us most of us it will have a very mild
to moderate course it's gonna be a bad
cold and we're gonna get over it and
we're gonna move forward obviously what
we're worried about our people 60 and
above and every decade older the death
rate can go up and still most of those
people are going to get better and do
fine what we're trying to do now is
build the medical infrastructure to
handle the elderly and the people with
other medical conditions and then buy
some time till the drugs that look like
they're working can be ready so we can
actually use them to lessen the effect
of the disease
and David those drugs are talking about
that that deals with the impact once
you're having breathing problems and
issues like that they're helping with
those things the symptoms is that
correct well some of them help with the
symptoms and some of them are a class of
antivirals you know this is an RNA virus
it gets inside our cell uses our own
machinery to divide and there are drugs
now that can block that some were meant
for HIV some were meant for Ebola but
they were already developed and they
exist and this virus uses the same
mechanism so we're gonna attack its
Achilles heel and it worked with the
other viruses and I think we're starting
to see that it's having benefit here
there's a lot of optimism in that regard
I know is there becomes more testing
available one of the questions that
people already have is you don't have
symptoms but you've been around somebody
perhaps that may have the disease what
do you do do you go ahead and get tested
or not I get that question and I'm sure
you do also you know literally every few
hours yeah you know right now the answer
is no is that anybody who you've been
exposed to somebody we want you to self
quarantine if you have mild symptoms I
still want you to stealth quarantine
right now and not go in for testing
you're gonna get better and if symptoms
get worse I want you to call your doctor
and get in for testing but right now
testing is not commonplace enough for
the masses to come in and you know I
don't want you sitting in an emergency
room for a couple of hours to get a test
either if you weren't positive going in
you may be positive coming out I mean
that's someone facetiously
but the notion really is is that we're
not ready for that mass testing yet
doctor as you noted and I think
everybody agrees there are a lot of
people who have it and don't know it we
know that already is there a point of
future if you had it then you'll know
and it went away and can you get this
virus again there's a great question so
number one is yes I mean we're going to
have a test where from a drop of blood
you can know hey I had this and I've
been exposed to it you know in many
countries they actually have that in
your cell phone you're green if you've
had it and you're red if you don't and
there's obviously a difference in how
you're aware for the next time this fire
stick comes around can you get the virus
again the true answer is we just don't
know
we've only been following this virus
since the month of December in 2019 so
we don't yet have the long term data to
know if the virus
we'll change it you can get it again or
in some people who don't have as potent
immune response maybe they have a mild
condition they can get it again also we
just don't know the answer we're gonna
know that over time but we're certainly
following those really closely and the
questions continue dr. David agus thank
you so much